from oxnard california the uh executive
vice president and chief
operating officer and director of player
personnel of the dallas cowboys
none other than stephen jones here on
the recharging show how are you steven
hey rich i'm doing good anything going
on with you these days
oh we got plenty plenty plenty going on
and
you know we're out here in oxnard where
it couldn't be a
better conditions to really uh put a
young football team to work and get
better and
really excited about uh you know what
this season holds for us we've got a
as i said a really young football team
but they're out there
getting better every day and uh it's
great seeing a bunch of uh
guys out there making plays and you know
jason's doing a great job of getting her
focus
on uh on getting better and we really
feel like we can improve upon what we
did last year and are ready to move
forward well how
how much of a conversation look you know
what we're all talking about in the
media
how much of of of the fact that zeke is
not in your camp
is being discussed uh on that practice
field
not at all it's uh it's just not a
factor with our coaches and our players
i know
certainly it's something the media likes
to uh to have something that they can
write about
and certainly uh you know i know our
fans are
are interested you know in terms of uh
you know when this thing might come to a
conclusion but it's certainly
you know a zero focus as far as our
players and our coaches and our
organization
other than other than what myself and
our salary cap guys are doing but at the
end of the day this is a
you know a distribution dilemma for us i
mean the money's going to go out the
door
it's going to be spent across the board
with our team
uh jerry it's just your and i's job to
decide
you know how to divide the pie and you
know everybody wants
their share and and as much as they can
get rightfully so i mean that's not the
player's problem
you know that's not dax issue that's not
zeke's issue that's not a marries issue
is to worry about who gets what i mean
that's our our issue
certainly it ultimately comes around to
them because it's what we're willing
how much of the power we're willing to
give them and you know all these are
great
football players and we're going to
exhaust all
all energy to get this done and
you know we want each one of these guys
to walk away very happy
you know with their business with their
contract situation it's not anything
we're concerned about it's not anything
that we're
uptight about it's not anything we're
puzzled about it's just something
you know that's the business of football
and we have to continue to work on it
well obviously the fact that zeke is
withholding his services right now has
placed at least a pressure point one
believes
are you surprised that he did not show
up to oxnard stephen jones well we
expect all players that have a contract
to show up and
you know obviously he didn't uh you know
there's rules that pertain to
these type of things and we certainly
you know have to respect that
zeke's been a great football player for
us and uh you know he's a warrior on the
field and
uh you know we got great respect for him
and you know we just want to get uh
resolution at some point well in terms
of
your your uh i guess remedies there are
in the collective bargain
agreement remedies in terms of fines and
uh if he doesn't show for the preseason
game which it appears he will not
a week one game check is are the cowboys
doing that
uh we don't want to get into the details
of how we you know how we're
working behind the scenes i don't think
that's really fruitful
for anybody as i said we've got nothing
but the greatest respect for all three
of these guys
uh as i said it's a distribution dilemma
right uh we've
we've drafted well hats off to will
mcclay and our scouting staff and our
coaching staff and
all the work that we put into you know
putting a great young football team
together and we certainly
don't want to see these young players
that we've drafted over the years walk
out the door and that's why
you know it's a it's a high class
problem it's a good problem to have we
want to continue to have it
but how to keep all these young players
and you know it doesn't end with these
three i mean as soon as
i promise you there's guys laying around
in these hotel rooms out here that are
you know that want their turn and and
want their time at bat
in terms of what their contract may look
at so
you know it's not anything it's just
part of the business it's not anything
we're frustrated with it's not anything
you know that you you know you ha every
team has to confront in terms of how
they divide up their salary cap and
certainly
we're no different than others and we'll
continue to work at it and
feel comfortable that ultimately we'll
get a resolution
stephen jones cowboys executive vice
president as well as coo
director of player personnel here on the
rich eisen show
so um i
there there was one thing that i just
would love to ask you about too you you
mentioned uh about le'veon bell's
contract perhaps
changing the way you approached zeke
throughout this non-playing season
certainly since at the combine you
talked about how gurley's contract might
be a start
is that accurate yeah i think it was a
start but then you
like any contract every contract that
gets done in this league affects others
and uh if the if if uh
if le'veon's contract would have been
hired it would have affected it when uh
mike thomas does the deal it affects the
receiver market when
uh you know when uh aaron rodgers does a
deal it affects the quarterback market
when tom brady does a deal it affects it
so uh you know you know le'veon bell
you know he had unfettered free agency
no draft picks attached to him he had 32
teams that could pay him and
you know he he ended up getting what he
got and so uh does it affect it of
course it does
does do we think zeke's uh
right at the top of the running of the
running back core in this league i think
zeke's rare just like you know gurley
was playing to rare abilities and
obviously le'veon has as well and these
are all great players and they all
deserve
uh you know deserve to get the money
that they ultimately get
so uh last one for you on these
contracts uh
do you do you do you and uh your dad
like the conversation
i mean just that there is buzz because
it seems like you're comfortable with
what other teams might find
uncomfortable you know you said you're
not
phased you're this is part of the
business it just seems like this is
comes
hand in glove sometimes with the dallas
cowboys stephen well
you know it's it's like you said that's
what comes
uh you know with being uh you know one
of the top uh
uh top teams in the country if not the
world in terms of uh
you know how people perceive the cowboys
we're
you know we don't take that for granted
rich it's a you know
certainly an honor to get to to be a
part of the cowboys i know our players
feel that way i know our coaches feel
that way
you know one of the things i'd say again
i know dax zeke and amari all want to be
here they want to they want to wear the
star they want to be a part of the
cowboys but we are comfortable with it i
mean
you know jerry and i've been around here
for 30 years and
you know last i checked he's got the
final call and still does but uh
you know i see us being around for
another 30 years so
you know this is just part of it this is
part of the business we're very
comfortable
in this you know at the end of the day i
think our fans believe that we want
what's best
for this team no one wants to get back
to a super bowl worse
than jerry and hopefully i'm right there
as well
i know how bad i want it but uh
you know in order for us to do that
everybody's gotta
uh you know everybody's gotta understand
we're trying to do what's best for this
organization and at the same time
you know try to you know we want our
players to be happy and
you know you know we're in that star
they get a lot of opportunities they get
a lot of
opportunities to make money off the
field uh you know we noted last year
that of the
top four seats in the booths on on our
networks
the dallas cowboys had three of them of
the top four
in terms of the color and uh you know
these guys get opportunities after
football it's a
you know it's it's a great place to play
but you know the biggest ache
that joey and i have right now is we
haven't won a super bowl
and uh a long long time and it's uh
you know we've got to continue to look
for better ways to do things because the
way we hadn't been the way we've been
doing them
as of late hasn't worked so we continue
to look for the right answer
a few minutes left with stephen jones
cowboys executive uh vp
cool right here on the rich eisen show
let's put your competition committee hat
on now stephen if you don't mind
one of the last times we talked was when
uh the pass interference
conversation about being reviewable was
up in the air it has now been settled
there's a one-year
i guess pilot program one would say uh
is
is this what you wanted you you like the
end result of the conversation here
you know i i felt like there was a i
ultimately went along with there was a
need to do something after the new
orleans game
uh you know to make an attempt to right
or wrong
but am i am i comfortable with
it not totally i think this is going to
be a challenge
for our officials it's going to be a
challenge for our league and
you know it's going to be very
interesting to see how this works out
and
you know i don't think anyone was for
you know for voting it in full time
let's see how this goes
uh there are going to be some challenges
out there but uh
you know we've got the best in the
business i think our officials are the
very best
in the business i think we've got a
great staff
you know in new york and uh you know
we're going to execute this
and if anyone can do it i got confidence
our people can do it well i know every
single time i talk to you whether it's
on this show
stephen or off the air whenever i do
cross paths with you you always mention
it seems to me more than
anybody else in the competition can be
about unintended consequences of rules
and wanting to make sure
that everything's discussed and
everything is covered and obviously this
this rule i'm already sensing an
unintended consequence
which is just like anything that's
reviewable once the review process is
open
it's open for review even if it wasn't
asked by the coach
to be reviewed and and to me that is
definitely not the intent
the intended uh spirit of making pass
interference
reviewable that's the one that really
gets me and i think that fans are going
to be
freaking out about stephen i wonder what
you think if that is
well like i said rich it's the
unintended consequences that bite you i
think
if you were to ask any one of our
members on the competition committee
you know there's they all have their
concerns and uh
but at the same time i think it's
something that we needed to give a go
and uh like i said i think we've got the
very best officials
i think they do a great job anytime
you're under a microscope if any one of
us were under the microscope they're
under
you know with television the way it is
this day and time and the number of
cameras that we have on the field
you know it's you're gonna have issues
and uh
you're gonna have things where people
question or second guess
and you know we just uh we just need to
do this and look at it and
you know you know we've done things
before with rules and
uh you know we'll evaluate this one very
closely and we'll evaluate it as the
season's going on
and uh you know we'll we'll get on our
calls and
we'll critique and see if there's
anything we can do better as we move
forward but this is
certainly something new and this is
certainly something we'll be watching
closely and as you always know i make
suggestions though stephen i don't just
you know we should you know we love our
fa hey
they love our fans we love our media
that's what they're for
and uh you know the game uh y'all make
the game what it is
here it is here's my suggestion here's
my suggestion for you okay
is that is that you tweak it that past
interference
is not in the bucket of always
reviewable
once the the review process is open you
have to specifically
ask for it to be reviewed and you
cannot use it to see opi
when you're asking for dpi and vice
versa just
remove that from the bucket of
everything's reviewable and maybe
we're it's tweaked yeah to the point
what do you think of that well i i think
it's certainly something
we're going to continue to discuss and
it's a great point
and uh okay good you know these things
are a work in progress rich there's no
question and as we uh see this thing
play out in the preseason
uh you know obviously we're going to be
watching it very closely as we really
get a full slate of games
as we move forward and we see how this
thing plays out
uh it's going to be watched very closely
and it's suggestions like yours that
we'll keep an eye on and
see what the unintended consequences are
and we'll move forward from there
all right in closing with you stephen
then um since i just took a moment for
myself i'm going to continue with that
if you don't mind there is an eye in
rich and
eisen a few weeks ago on this show when
zeke did not show up for work for you in
oxnard california
i said i was so confident that that you
guys and
dallas would get this deal done that uh
if zeke elliott does not appear
in week one against the giants for you
stephen jones and he's a healthy guy
that i would my sound guy that i have
across the way from new jersey
he wears a callaway hat because it's a
sponsor the show i think you'll
appreciate our branding here
that i would eat his hat off the top of
his head
am i going to eat a hat week one of this
season stephen jones
well we have a lot of confidence that we
can get deals done
and so i certainly hope uh that
uh that there's not going to be any hat
eating on the eyes and show
okay so we have a lot of confidence that
we can get these done and
we get all three of these contracts done
and hopefully
uh even more young players as we move
forward no i know you got a super bowl
to win there's wins and losses the
dallas cowboys your
passionate fan base just you know there
there is me and what i have on the line
too stephen just understand that well
i'll certainly be thinking of that as we
move forward
okay so when this on the dotted line
just you say we're thrilled to have zeke
here
and rich you don't have to eat a hat
basically just i love it
thanks for the call stephen really
appreciate it you got it stephen jones
cowboys executive vice president for
more of the rich eisen show
tune to audience channel 239 on directv
for free on br live or download the rich
eisen show app